you know back in my day growing up in
the utopian garden of eden period known
as 1990s i did not
have sexual relations with that woman we
had kids shows which uh the interesting
thing about the kids show is that they
were they were shows for kids that's
what they were for and some of them were
better than others some were kind of
weird some were kind of stupid some were
artistic masterpieces like for example
the nickelodeon show salute your shorts
which is a 90s show that every 90s kid
remembers and then is shocked to
discover that every other 90s kid
remembers it too now the thing about
these shows is that their primary goal
was to entertain as i remember that's
different from the situation that we
have today where kids shows seem to
consider entertainment sort of a
secondary concern the primary goal now
is to ensure that the children in the
audience adopt the correct
political and ideological viewpoints
wheel of morality turn turn turn tell us
the lesson that we should learn and by
correct i mean those views that are in
keeping with the mainstream beliefs of
our culture and by that i mean incorrect
so by correct i mean incorrect we'll
begin with the latest example
and maybe the worst this one is fresh
out of the indoctrination oven it's the
show muppet babies in which gonzo comes
out as a gender-fluid cross-dresser yes
really
let's watch there you are you missed our
royal ball we met the most amazing
princess but they ran away and all they
left behind was this
everyone there's something i need to
tell you
the princess who came to your ball
tonight
was me
i'm gonzarella
but gonzo why didn't vu tell us
because you all expected me to look a
certain way i don't want you to be upset
with me
but i don't want to do things just
because that's the way they've always
been done either
i want to be me
oh gonzo
we're sorry
it wasn't very nice of us to tell you
what to wear to our ball you're our
friend and we love you any way you are
yeah of course we
see this is why it's so important have a
father in the home uh it's clear that
gonzo doesn't have a father in the home
to say hey take that thing off you look
stupid get that thing off of you take
that ridiculous thing off
you know some people will point out um
that kid shows in the past have had
episodes where boys dress as girls and
and that's true uh but in the past
whether it was a kid show or something
for older kids or or you know older
audiences something like mrs doubtfire
movie from the 90s robin williams in the
past this plot point was always played
for laughs right it was supposed to be
funny the point was that boys look
stupid in girls clothes and we should
laugh about it oh yeah well we know what
i think who cares what you think you're
a girl now
um now the point is that wearing girls
clothes is great and courageous and more
boys should try it you know if you've
raised your your kids correctly and they
and they were to watch them up at babies
and they saw that
they would start laughing like if my
boys watch my babies which they won't
but if they did and they saw they would
just laugh hysterically because they
would say that's so silly and ridiculous
which it is but now it's the the
the goal is quite the opposite of that
which is among other things extremely
creepy next we have the show arthur um
one that i remember from my childhood as
well the show about a lovable aardvark i
think that's what he is that could be
wrong he used to be lovable um anyway
he's lost a bit of his charm now that
he's pushing critical race theory hey
arthur hey buster did you see that video
yeah i just watched it it was awful i
can't believe someone would be hurt like
that just because they're black racism
is so unfair no one should ever judge
someone by the color of their skin but
how could it happen here in elwood city
right outside the sugar bowl buster it
happens everywhere i was talking to mrs
mcgrady the other day she said there's a
really long history of black people not
being treated fairly in this country it
has to stop
we have to do something yeah
[Music]
but what can we do i mean i'm eight i
can't even fry an egg on my own i don't
know
maybe mrs mcgrady can give us some ideas
hold on
hello boys
i'm so glad you reached out to me
yes i saw the video too and let me tell
you it made my blood boil me too it also
made me scared i mean this happened in
our neighborhood it is scary buster
but you should know that a lot of
grown-ups are fighting racism and
working hard to keep us all safe
why does this keep happening mrs mcgrady
well racism is like a disease if you
don't treat it it's just gonna get worse
okay let me jump in there mrs grady if i
could uh mrs mcgrady whatever your name
is why does it keep happening well for
the same reason that unicorns keep
sitting on your roof
that is it's not happening
like at all there have been
comparatively few unjustified police
shootings of anyone um statistically
this is this is undeniable from a
statistical standpoint
and almost none of them
have any connection to racism so this is
not a thing that's actually happening
and yet yet the people behind arthur
want small children to imagine they live
in a country where black people are
being killed left and right for the
color of their skin just like walking on
the street they're just getting murdered
by the cops you really think someone
would do that just go on the internet
and tell lies and by the way side note
what what does does race even exist in
the arthur universe you can't just
invent a holiday arthur well sure you
can
my family celebrates kwanzaa and that
was invented for african americans by dr
molana karenga in 1966.
not sure what's going on there exactly
but let's keep going uh we'll stay on
the on the racial side of things with
this from a show that i don't even know
what the show is but it's called steven
universe here it is
[Music]
all right class can anyone tell me who
invented the light bulb
that's not entirely true the light bulb
could more rightfully be attributed to
lewis latimer the black inventor behind
the filament inside the bulb his
invention made light bulbs affordable
and efficient enough for the general
public bringing electric light into
household around the world well so now
you know
wait is that it hold on we're not going
to mention why he invented the filament
to create a better standard of living
for people who had only just been freed
from slavery are we going to ask why
kids are apparently learning about
thomas edison
and not learning about louis latimer
these textbooks are incomplete there
were black roman warriors black medieval
knights black classical musicians black
cowboys black fighter pilot where are
they
okay
um i i don't want to get into historical
debate with a cartoon but at the same
time no you could not attribute the
light bulb to louis latimer if you
actually care about things like the
truth and historical accuracy you know
those
little details like that yes
latimer innovated a filament for the
bulb he didn't invent the filament but
he did come up with a better longer
lasting filament which is great that
doesn't equate to inventing the light
bulb all right i could invent a more
durable
tire or a more reliable braking system
well i couldn't do that but somebody
could
that doesn't mean that i get to claim
that i invented the car though and i
can't have the car because it's already
been invented so there's that little
detail as for the actual inventor of the
lightbulb there is a debate that could
be had about who exactly that was edison
deserves
most of the credit that he gets joseph
swann is an english scientist also
developed in incandescent bulb
independently but joseph swann was white
so the fact is many of the most
important
inventions in modern society
were given to us by white people usually
men not all but a great many that's not
a racist statement that is just a fact
it's also not something to be ashamed of
or embarrassed about or competitive
about or angry about rather than trying
to steal this invention from thomas
edison
when he's not even around to defend
himself how about saying hey thanks
thomas adam edison
there at least one good good white guy
that's been out there there are many
others it turns out
all right so no list of woke children
shows would be complete without the
blues clues drag queen episode which
maybe you've seen by now but it's got to
be on the list so let's all
enjoy that once again hey blue look at
all these families hi families it's time
for a pride parade
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah this family has two mummies they
love each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big parade
families marching four by four hurrah
hurrah
families marching four by four hurrah
hurrah
trans members of this family all love
each other so proudly and they all go
marching in
the big parade come join the fun this by
the way is a show for preschoolers okay
like uh like three-year-olds
pushing drag queens and pansexuals do
you know what a typical plot for blue's
clues used to be
steve who it was the guy
he would lose his glue stick
and he'd have to find it
and he would ask blue hey blue do you
know where my glue stick is
and blue would be all uh coy about it
even though blue knows where the damn
glue stick is he won't just tell steve
where it is so he starts planting all
these clues around the house and steve
is very patient he's like okay i gotta
go through i'll do that we're gonna
spend 30 minutes looking for the damn
glue you just tell me where it is blue
but he doesn't do that he actually goes
and so that would be that's the whole
episode it's just
is just steve trying to find his glue
stick and at the end he finds it
and that's the end of the show
that was a kid's show and now we have um
pansexual toads
and bisexual turtles singing about their
favorite sexual orientation so a little
bit of a different approach i suppose
okay one more we'll close with um
lesbian horses on my little pony let's
watch this you three truly have a gift
for helping ponies oh thanks aunt
holiday but i'm not sure we can take
credit for this one
of course you can you encourage that
cult to try new things and because you
all believed in him he succeeded
i could use that kind of help
come on auntie lofty you already have
your cutie mark a lot of good it does me
i can't decide what theme to give this
quilt
i've run out of inspiration how about
apples puppies
or cotton candy or ballet what about a
wonderful quilt see leave it to you
three to come up with more ideas than
i've had in a year now that's talent
oh is that it okay
um
i i you know i was i was waiting because
well first of all i didn't mean to
misgender the horses that's actually not
a horse that's a unicorn it would seem
but you know how bad it's gotten
that that that was the tamest thing
we saw i was like waiting for that was
downright quaint and conservative in
comparison to what you normally get from
kid shows these days i mean it's only a
lesbian couple on my little pony
the lesbian unicorns they're not even
into like bdsm or anything there's no
subplot where one of them gets a sex
change
this is old-fashioned
really
that's how bad it's gotten
and it's just one more reason why
you should turn the tv off
send your kids outside let them go run
and play
scrape their knees
bloody their noses a little bit
minor injuries await them outdoors but
at least
they'll still have their souls
and their brains
[Music]
well if you want to see more
lesbian horses and non-binary dolphins
make sure to like and subscribe so hit
that like button right now